shai asks how does humor play a role in
business shy this is a really great
question and you've been known to ask me
great questions oh you thought I forgot
about we work I actually think it plays
a role but I would say it plays a role
in the way that a plays a role in all of
life humor happens to be one of the most
attractive personality traits I mean
look at the tragic events of this week
of Robin Williams the enormous emotion
an outcry and sadness and feelings that
have come from the American public shows
you like how much a comedian can get
very deeply ingrained in the world and
he was one of those greats to you know I
honestly use humor I mean a lot of you
watch my keynotes I like the fancy and
think that a lot of my keynotes take on
a stand-up comedy routine
I find myself having the ability to
drive difficult HR conversations and
selling things through to clients or to
the general public by leveraging humor I
think humor is an enormous ly attractive
trait that is a very important part of
business but no more important than the
other things that are people are very
attracted to and others which is caring
and empathy self-awareness gratitude
kindness beauty you know it's just
another core tenant that if you've got
it use it